oil is where you find and the search for
oil is never ended constant it spans the
globe probing a lake in Venezuela a
desert in Arabia a Louisiana bayou
or rugged barely explored northern
Canada and you take oil where you find
argue live in hard to breathe in hard to
work in land the people of the lands
different language customs traditions
very neither oil nor the oil seeker and
alter a culture overnight yet oil brings
change this is to Lara
Peru and so is this national customs
when treated with respect and dignity no
barrier to an oil company's operation
socially culturally man is supremely
adaptable and physically there is no
great difference between the American
the proof
the Finn or the lady the clefts of the
problem is adapting physically unchanged
human beings to a physically changed
world this all-important problem fitting
the worker to his industrial environment
is a prime concern to the medical
department of Jersey standard here at 30
Rockefeller Plaza headquarters of a
worldwide organization of affiliated
companies one of the most advanced
industrial health programs is focused
all company medical activities are based
upon one theory simply this a healthy
employee is a happy employee and a happy
employee
who knows his medical limitations and
who is assigned to a job in keeping with
his abilities to perform as an efficient
employee to assist in the health
maintenance of the employee called for a
new interpretation of medicine as
applied to the needs of Industry we
think of it as a positive program as an
active cooperation with the employee in
maintaining his capacity for a rewarding
healthy life rather than waiting behind
a desk waiting for something to happen
to the employee before we do anything
more and more the doctor and industry
will spend his time keeping the fit fit
rather than trying to make the onset to
yes
industry is rapidly changing the
environment of man but man is having
trouble adapting himself satisfactorily
let's face it many of these new
industrial developments have created new
medical problems like air pollution
water pollution high altitude flying
many others
that is why this field of medicine and
industry is no longer confined to the
plant now we are concerned with medical
problems involving all employed
individuals the activities of the doctor
and Industry are in the neutral zone
between management and labor those
activities are tremendously varied and
numerous in this industry certainly with
over 500 different occupations for the
health of so many thousands of personnel
to consider the vast distances between
installations adds to the complication
to handle this task then new techniques
are needed with coordination of thought
and action among all those who are
interested in an employee welfare is
most essential three doctors in industry
must develop a program applicable to
large installations and small ones to
our aim is to give the same sort of
service as we have here at the central
office to the employees and say Hamburg
or Rio de Janeiro or in New Jersey
and in places where employee is not
isolated they must have medical
supervision too
[Applause]
wherever the employee is the facilities
the care and the attitudes of those
attending him must be tough and wherever
the employee is the standard of medical
supervision must be the same this of
course takes planning in a big total way
in our view four types of medical
practice make up this total medical
program we'd like to tell you about it
jerseys four part program preventive
medicine constructive medicine educative
medicine and curative medicine
[Music]
now let us examine these one-by-one
starting first with preventive medicine
the successive preventive medicine is
often reflected in a graph a sliding
downward graph in Venezuela for example
malaria had always been asked urged
chewing and maiming thousands every year
now the disease has been eradicated by a
positive program of action workout 5
management on the basis of guidance by
the doctor in charge mosquito breeding
areas were made target number one
those who became victims of the disease
were given immediate efficient thorough
treatment but the overall emphasis was
on prevention rather than cure and this
emphasis paid off in ways far more
important than lines on a graph in show
so successful was the company's
anti-malarial campaigned that in careful
hospital bed space formally allotted to
malaria cases has been converted to
doctors officers in Aruba the major
problem was amoebic dysentery for years
the disease had been endemic in the area
in 1936 the Health Unit of the company
began a concerted attack on amoebic
dysentery new sanitary techniques in the
preparation of food were installed and
carefully supervised a boil or open sore
can do a lot of damage preventive
measures some simple some more
complicated but the result was dramatic
frequency rate of the disease dropped
shuckman amoebic dysentery was virtually
wiped out love healthy happier employees
in a woman
in New York a company employee bound for
the Near East visits the Health Center
for immunization shots that will protect
him from the disease's prevalent at his
destination preventive medicine getting
it before it gets you
periodically help officers from
affiliates located in all corners of the
globe meet in New York to discuss new
approaches to old problems new problems
constantly arising their reports are
carefully recorded out of these
discussions this exchange of information
from the dynamics of a modern practical
program for disease prevention to
implement the program the Industrial
physician works closely with a skilled
efficient team the industrial hygienists
can answer key questions on employee
working conditions location of jobs
materials handled the chemist has an
important contribution so as the
toxicologist the nurse the
epidemiologist the biostatistician the
safety engineer all of them with heavy
responsibilities in the overcoming of
industrial problems but let's see what
happens when this team goes into action
1942 the year the first commercial units
for fluid catalytic cracking was put
into operation by a Jersey standard
affiliate a heavy fraction from this
process contains a hydrocarbon which
under certain conditions has been found
to cause cancer in humans question was
this heavy fraction of potential cancer
hazards the answer had to be found
representatives of the Health Unit and
management's met the go-ahead was given
cooperation of outstanding research
institutes was asked and given
experimental animals were painted with
oil samples
this investigation and others
demonstrated that certain of these heavy
fractions under specific conditions
caused cancerous growths on animals
conclusion a cancer hazard existed where
workers came in contact with bees oiled
more information was needed how many men
were in contact with these oils to what
degree at company laboratories a
full-scale attempt was made to eliminate
or diminish the possible disease-causing
chemical compounds in the oil employees
exposed to the possible disease-causing
oil were examined every three months and
special attention was paid through warts
tumors and other abnormalities of the
skin in the refinery's lines tanks and
other pieces of equipment containing the
possibly diseased producing oil were
painted orange for identification
employees were instructed to remove oil
from the skin immediately by thorough
washing with soap and water
protective clothing was provided and
required on all jobs where there was
possible contact with these oils as a
result of bees and other precautions
there have been no cases of skin cancer
among workers since this program was
established a potential health problem
had been found investigated and
eliminated by the application of the
techniques of preventive medicine
planned action in advance that is the
car for that event we know too often in
large-scale medical work the emphasis is
all upon disease while little attention
is paid to the individual as a total
person constructive medicine the second
of a four-part program of constructive
health maintenance tries to avoid this
defect its major concern is the health
of the whole man by adding life to years
constructive medicine utilizes every
facility and judgment at a doctor's
disposal so that he can be texts to
these early enough to do something
simple and positive about it at a price
that the employee can afford to pay in
industry the cornerstone of constructive
medicine is in the concepts of the
complete health inventory medical
examination the inventory medical
examination is a total evaluation of the
individual's health this employee has
been with the company for 15 years he is
now taking his 8 periodic physical the
examination includes a psychological
evaluation of the individual how about
the job is he up to it if he isn't not
only the job will suffer but more
important the man's health will begin to
break down
but psychologically and physically the
total medical inventory is evaluated
the examinations are voluntary no
employee is forced to take them and for
those who do the examination results are
confidential strictly between the
employee and the physician days later
physician and employee discussed the
findings advice is given for correcting
existing defects and if necessary a
private physician is recommended whether
for the executive at a desk or a man in
the field constructive medicine helps
the employee understand his capacity for
achievement it is imperative for every
individual to know what his health
potential is that's why all employees
wherever they are whatever their jobs
are encouraged to visit the health
center whenever they want to today to
any one of the many health centers of
Jersey or its affiliates employees come
for periodic physical inventories
willingly gladly
at times an employee will come in with a
health problem that worries her deeply
affects her work her enjoyment of living
a complete inventory will help get to
the root at the trouble which at times
is minor sometimes could be serious if
not attended to but it is attended to
the examination is thorough the facts
are obtained and arrangements are made
to forward her complete medical file to
the physician of her choice if
hospitalization is required the cost
will be covered by her health insurance
and the company will see to it that she
suffers no loss of paid
ten days later the employee comes back
to the company health center for checkup
the problem was not dodged it was met
and resolved early so that the employee
can all be the happier fuller life the
end purpose of constructive medicine
[Music]
not all the time is the story of
pleasant one at times an employee will
report to the health unit with a
specific complaint her profile revealed
she has not reported at regular
intervals for a periodic checkup
the receptionist makes arrangements for
the woman who receive a complete
physical examination
the examination reveals a serious
condition which should have been checked
long before
immediate hospitalization is suggested
but though everything possible will be
done for her the probability is that the
corrective action will be too late
there is only one answer to the tragedy
of a person who died because of medical
action called for too late that is
education the spreading of accurate
information about the constructive
positive approach that modern medicine
is applied to the medical needs of
Industry when the employee understands
that the idea of going to a doctor only
when you feel sick is as extinct as a
hoop skirt when the concept of the
medical inventory is thoroughly grasped
by medical men as well as laymen only
then the benefits will be felt by
everybody that is the reason behind the
third phase of a modern constructive
health maintenance program for industry
this phase can be described as educative
medicine first of all it involves
extensive training of doctors nurses and
other medical personnel within Jersey
standard and its affiliated companies
through the home headquarters each year
come company doctors from all over the
world it is a give-and-take relationship
a free discussion of problems an
exchange of information among doctors
who have specialized in medicine as
applied to the needs of Industry
forums are conducted on specific medical
problems of Industry as here the
problems of alcoholism the individual
doctors observed and later on their
comments will be asked for their frank
comments because educated medicine is a
two-way street
often it is not possible or practical
for the doctors and nurses of every
affiliate to visit the home headquarters
so the home headquarters will visit the
affiliate
[Music]
mutual problems are discussed beyond the
spot situation is reviewed everywhere
within the organization affiliated
companies as here in Venezuela the
training of nurses is never neglected
for a competent staff of nurses and
technicians is a must
medical students the doctors of tomorrow
are invited at company expense for a
program of discussion meetings and
visits to various facilities
public and private health agencies are
continually made aware of the work of
the health unit under the educated phase
of the program employees come to
understand their physical makeup and
their limitations the employee suddenly
stricken with stomach cramps will pass
up the home remedy and if the condition
continues he will check it with a doctor
the wife of an employee who suffers a
heart attack
knows immediately what to do stay put
and call a doctor
it is in instances like these that
educated medicine proves it's worth
the fourth phase of a modern
constructive health maintenance program
for industry there's one which is very
often overemphasize the curative phase
all too often clinical facilities have
been set up by companies for the sole
purpose of taking care of a medical
emergency after it occurs this is unfair
not only to the employee but to the
company concerned as well it is strictly
a case of locking the barn door after
the horse has been sold so this is not
to say that medicine has applied to the
needs of modern industry should ignore
the best facilities and procedures
available to deal with accidents and
emergencies as they occur for our family
[Music]
this is an emergency
[Music]
[Music]
back at the health unit the men's leg is
x-rayed emergency care is given to ease
the pain to start the healing process on
its way
the employee has a badly sprained ankle
the patient's personal physician is
notified and arrangements are made for
hospitalization in accordance with his
wishes once the elementary curative care
is started the burden of care must fall
on the individual employee receives a
full report to turn over to his own
private physician good health is not a
gift it is a personal responsibility
which must be worked for the employee
has helped in this search for good
health he has the help of management a
progressive management which has set up
a positive vigorous medical program with
adequate facilities and personnel at
every installation to carry out the
four-part program for better health
preventive medicine constructive
medicine educating medicine curative
medicine
today medical teamwork intelligent
planning are helping the worker to
achieve better health and a happier life
the employee games management games this
then is the reward of a positive program
for industrial health